foreign
this is a story about recycling gone
awry
and how claims of sustainability from
large companies are going up in flames
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
agar is a city 80 miles north of New
Delhi the surrounding area is known for
its sugar and paper mills now it's taken
on a much darker claim to fame as a
Dumping Ground for ton after ton of
American Plastic
field of plastic is right behind a
village there are children playing
nearby we've walked through it and
surprisingly most of this plastic comes
from overseas mostly from the U.S and
Canada and one brand stands out
Amazon literally there are Amazon
shipping bags all over this field how
did this plastic waste from overseas get
here
paper mills rely on imported Waste Paper
because it's cheaper than wood pulp and
India can't Source enough paper for
recycling domestically
problem is that plastic packaging waste
is often
often it's estimated that as much as 500
000 tons of plastic waste is coming into
India every year
much of that plastic ends up being used
as fuel by local Industries including
paper and sugar Mills
residents say they know when plastic was
burned overnight because they usually
wake up to a layer of gray and black ash
that coats Terraces crops and anything
left Outdoors
vimla Devi is a longtime resident who's
developed health problems in the last
few years because of pollution from
burning plastic
foreign
[Music]
plumes of thick black smoke are
billowing from these facilities all
around us we don't know for sure what
they're burning but experts say black
smoke is one indication that plastic's
being burnt
[Music]
rahu Kumar is an activist in a village
in musafir nagar he leads a group of
eight volunteers working to raise
awareness of air and water pollution
caused by the industrial burning of
plastic
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
but here the Global Recycling system's
failings are hard to deny
labels reveal just how far the waste has
traveled there's plastic trash from
Nestle Costco's Kirkland and Under Armor
All thrown out by U.S and Canadian
consumers some 7 000 miles away
still some paper industry Executives in
Lucifer nagar say the plastic that comes
with paper recycling isn't a problem
pankaj Agarwal runs a paper mill and is
Chairman of the paper manufacturers
Association for the state of uttar
Pradesh
this is important
yeah maybe Canada or maybe from U.S
this is a mixed waste
but there is no much contamination you
can see there is not much plastic
at a dump site close to agarwal's Paper
Mill one plastic envelope with the
United States Postal Service label stood
out it had a name and address printed
directly on it it had been shipped to
Lori smila who we later found out was a
73 year old retiree from Sloatsburg in
Rockland County New York we tracked her
down from India
Lori it's Juan Hoff from Bloomberg News
thanks so much for joining us from
upstate New York so I found something
that used to belong to you this is a
United States Postal Service
envelope that arrived in your house once
and we found it in this field what do
you make of it
it's phenomenal because I I know that I
do receive packages on a regular basis
I'm sure that one contained something I
ordered uh the question is how in the
world did it end up
um in India well you know as consumers
we think that when we put something into
the recycling bin I mean what's the
expectation there and I'm wondering how
you feel about that for years we've
thought that everything that we're doing
is the right thing but obviously that
wasn't the case
I feel sorry for anyone who lives uh
within a five mile radius of this site
you're standing on
[Music]
Amazon wouldn't comment on the presence
of its packaging in Lucifer nagar but in
a statement the company said it was
committed to minimizing waste and
helping customers recycle their
packaging
the uttar Pradesh pollution control
board that oversees musafar nagar said
it fined nearly half of the more than 30
Mills in the city for burning plastic
and not managing the ash from their
Milling process just in October
still the problem isn't going away
the grandmother worries what the
pollution from overseas will do to the
Next Generation
foreign
[Music]